ecowas is getting tough with guinea
after the military coup there the
economic community of west african
states has imposed travel bans and
financial sanctions on the country's new
leaders and their families now the
summit in ghana equals leaders also
demanded the unconditional release of
guinness president alfa conde as well as
a quote very short transition period
the transition should not last
more than six months so six months
election should be held
because
the election will allow the count the
restoration of the constitutional order
in the republic of guinea
now these demands are the blocks
toughest response yet to the military
takeover in guinea earlier this month
the announcement was made as school
leaders in the country wrapped up a week
of consultations with various
stakeholders to map out a framework for
a transitional government we'll soon be
exploring the implications of this
school for guinea and the region but
first let's recap what happened
jubilation in kona cree guinness
military takeover was popular on the
streets of the capital
it's a victory for the young people of
guinea we are really happy we say well
done to the guinean army to the special
forces
youth has won today we are all free
everyone
[Applause]
shortly after the coup the military
released a video showing him in their
custody unharmed his current location
still unknown
alpha condier human rights professor and
former opposition activist was elected
in 2010 after decades of military rule
he became guinea's first democratic
leader since independence from france in
1958
but after two terms conde changed the
constitution allowing himself to stand
for a third term opposition protests
followed and dozens were killed
the military said poverty and endemic
corruption had driven them to topple the
president
the junta promised to install the
transitional government but they gave no
timeline and made no mention of
elections
the first principle we have imposed on
ourselves
is to not repeat the mistakes of the
past
the decisions that have to govern this
new era will be taken in an inclusive
and participatory manner
inclusive a participative
promises at the people's palace in kona
but will they be as swift as equos is
demanding
coup leaders have yet to come up with a
road map to return civilian rule to
guinea
joining me now is niagara lay bagayoko
she is chair of the african security
sector network and has done extensive
research on security and especially
african francophone countries hello
niagara nice to see you again now many
in guinea have shown support for the
military takeover they say it was needed
to counteract alfa conde's
constitutional coup what's your response
to them
this is exactly
the matter at stake in fact we have
uh
the
the were in the situation where you have
two illegitimacy
which are competing one to each other
first of course you have this
unconstitutional
military
coup
in constitutional access to power with
arms but in front of this you also do
have this
unconstitutional cert mandate we for
which president conte
had run
so that is one of the reason why it is
very difficult for the population to
consider that they are coming from a
democracy to an authoritarian military
regime and this is also one of the
reason why there are not a lot of
sadness
nor
regrets
expressed to
the caesar of power of the military
against president conte
let's let's move on to to still on the
military they've been consulting with
various stakeholders is that a plausible
start to a transition to democracy
it's very hard to say at this stage
what is in my view
rather positive in the
recent consultations and talks which
just happened is the fact that all the
communities of the countries have been
associated to it white
colonel dumbo
is coming from the same ethnic groups as
president conte and president alfa conde
was used to
use
ethnicity
and community belonging to nurture
discourses of exclusion
especially from the malinke community
where he is coming from against the
fulani community and the fact that
the opposition leader
seleucid and darlene dello
has been
very
satisfied as far as he said
about the talks he's been able to be
involved too
is in my view a positive development but
it is difficult to say if this inclusive
approach will pave the way to democracy
itself
now as we all know guinea is just the
latest in a series of coups in west
africa is democracy in crisis in the
region
i think that the democracy
is in danger and the
position which have been taken recently
especially by
continental and regional organization
are really a matter of
worrying because
we saw that the coup
which happened just after the death of
chad leader of idris ignored
when
janta
conducted basis on sun to power in
violation of the constitution was not
really condemned by the african union
and just after happened the second coup
in mali in las may
because i think that this non-decision
of the african union was a kind of
encouragement for other military to uh
sales power and we can see that indeed
in less than one year around in eight
months this is the third coupe which is
happening in central and western africa
are you briefly on this one are you in a
way suggesting that there could be more
crews coming up
it is absolutely a
possibility
because there has been also first there
has been other uh
leaders who have ruled for certain terms
where there was they were not allowed to
by the initial constitutions and also
because there is also lots of
dissatisfaction in a lot of countries
and a lot of distrust from the
populations and also lastly because i
think that the multilateral african
system which is meant to promote rule of
law a constitutional change of regime a
due difference of human rights and not
being
enough tough
to
impose those principles to its state
member so yes i think that democracy is
at risk today but not only from the
military leaders but also from civilian
leaders who are not respecting the legal
frameworks
okay niagarale bagayoko political
scientist thank you
and it's not just guinea across western
and central africa three more countries
have been hit by military takeovers as
mali niger and chad first mali guinea's
direct neighbor now since last august
there have been two successful coups in
their country malian forces mutinied in
august 2020 forcing 75-year-old
president ibrahim bubakar keta to resign
after months of protest
then in may of this year another coup
the army stripped the next president 71
year-old bindao of power after just nine
months in office our vice president
kennel assimigota seized power he's just
37 making him one of africa's youngest
leaders
further east in niger the 2021 election
of mohammed bazum was the first
democratic handover of power in the
country's post-independence history his
integration looked to be in jeopardy in
march when heavy gunfire broke out close
to the president's official residence in
the capital nyame the rebel military
unit had tried to reach the palace only
to be beaten back by the presidential
guard within hours the government
declared the coup thwarted and bazoom
was integrated two days later
and nigeria's neighbor chad saw the
military cease power in april this year
after the death of long-time president
idris debi the army installed one of
their own debi son mahamat idris db
asked the new president
ignoring and repealing the constitution
and suspending parliament
well to analyze these developments we
have invited christine in onto the show
he's director of faculty of academic
affairs and research with the kofi annan
international peacekeeping training
center in accra ghana welcome to dw news
africa sir now in just over a year
before military coups or attempted
cruise in africa what makes particularly
west africa so prone to military
takeovers
well i think west africa is not more
pruned than any other
region and the west africa faces
a particular challenge with the
unwillingness
by the political elites particularly
heads of states
to comply
with the
norms and values inherent in the
instruments that they have signed around
constitutionalism respect for human
rights the rule of law transitional
politics
and inclusive politics
so in all the countries that you've
mentioned with the exception of probably
niger
we've seen situations where
the regimes have tinkered
with the constitution's extended their
states including la cote d'ivoire for
example
and that generates
some discomfort that generates some
anger
um and it is
those
frustrations
that bubble up
and contribute
to the crew proneness that we are
talking about
now that clearly seems like a challenge
so should we be concerned that the
latest school in guinea for instance
could drive even more military takeovers
in the region
we have a very short space of time
within which to act
that echoers must take the lead
and
moderate
what it means by constitutional
takeovers of power
constitutional takeover of power begins
when the constitution is changed to
allow for third termism
to limit the ability or access of
opposition parties to the media
suppress
civil society engagement and criticisms
all these come together
to undermine and threaten
constitutionalism and democratic
processes
when we fail
to protect these rights
we almost give the military cut blanche
unfortunately so
to take over power but the military
has no role
in the politics
and in the democratic
behavior of west african states
the failure of the political elite
unfortunately creates the space for the
family
well unfortunately that doesn't seem to
be the case looking at the recent coups
that we have the military have always
been involved in that right now guinness
coup however seems to have popular
support
is there any evidence that a military
coup can restore democracy
no i think what is going to happen
um is that the period
of
you know romantic engagement uh will
you know end very soon
the military will come in with a
transition plan they will put down their
uniforms form a political party stage an
election
get the supreme court on their side and
hopefully
steal the
election and become democratic
um now that sends a pretty bad signal
you know so west africa i guess
um
is going through a terribly
unstable patch
but it's not all lost
with
leadership informed leadership from
abuja that is from ecowas
and from the more stable functional
democratic states
i think we we should be able to pull
back from the brain but it's going to be
a battle christine in with a kofi annan
international peacekeeping training
center in accra ghana thanks for your
insights
you